ruler I mean she's a senior
Communications advisor at the United
Nations High Commissioner Phil refugees
and she joins us by Skype from Amman
ruler thanks so much for being on the
program firstly what does this tragedy
say about the desperation of these
people
yes as you said it's the desperation and
the hopelessness
unfortunately like Zena had said people
are aware of the risk and yet they take
these Journeys we have seen the number
of people attempting to depart in the
number of boats departing double from 21
to 12 compared to 20 and that number
tripled if you compare it from January
to September 2022.
that shows how desperate these people
are in order to protect their families
and to provide for their families just
to remind the viewers in Syria inside
Syria's situation is very dire more than
90 of the population are living under
the poverty line in Lebanon more than 90
percent of Syrian refugees are living in
extreme poverty these are this says a
lot about the situation and what needs
to be done to help these people what we
call for is solidarity International
solidarity in line of what we call
responsibility sharing the International
Community must do more not only to
improve conditions for refugees and idps
and the communities that host them like
lava but it also must provide what we
call Safe Pathways legal ways for these
people to be able to move to a third
country where they have a better chance
to protect their families
uh roulette what does what's the UN
doing to help these people we heard from
our correspondent she said that Anwar is
lacking funds what impact is that having
of course lacking funds means that U.N
agencies like online like unhcr are not
able to reach all those who need
humanitarian assistance it means we have
to prioritize who is more vulnerable and
to be honest in this situations most
people are very vulnerable and it's a
very hard decision what is needed is
international solidarity to provide
These funds so humanitarian agencies can
reach these people international support
must be provided to hosting communities
like Lebanon like Jordan and more
important there has to be a will to find
solutions for these peoples as Zena said
many of these people have been living a
life of refugees in very dire conditions
for years now and it's time for people
to have Solutions as insight for Syrian
refugees for example they are in Lebanon
in a very direct economic situation and
there is a lot of pressure on them to go
back to Syria it's very hard for them to
go back to Syria for a number of reasons
some don't feel safe others decide
elements or reasons like lack of
livelihood lack of infrastructure or
schools no Health okay and that's a
major problem inside Syria now more than
14 million people need humanitarian
assistance
but the statistics are certainly Stark
as we continue to hear and you talk of
solutions but who's responsible for
finding the solution surely the UN needs
to put up its hand and say yes okay
Solutions are needed and this is how we
can tangibly help
yes um that's a very good question
unfortunately the UN alone cannot find
these Solutions there has to be a will
by the stakeholders whether it's the
countries where there is conflict
neighboring countries and Regional and
international Powers who have a lot of
staying usually in these conflicts and
there's so much money that's been put to
a fuel sometimes the conflict so some
there has to be a consensus that it's
time to stop we have to avoid more
conflicts we have to resolve the current
conflict and we have to be able to give
people a hope we have to be able to tell
them that they don't need to get on
these dangerous Journeys that there is a
way for them to provide to their
families to protect their children to
grant them a future without having to
put children on such risky votes as Dana
said you know many people had seen
sometimes family members go on these
boats and sink and drown in the sea and
yet they take the journey only because
they don't have another choice you have
to give them other options the thing
with Lebanon is is the economic
situation there is is nothing new and
why have these people been left in such
a dire situation for so long
well it is new it's it's a very Superior
economic crisis and it's hit the country
especially hard in the past two years
before Lebanese you know many of the
Lebanese are not used to these kind of
challenges and difficulties and this
this crisis that there is no light at
the end of the tunnel that it's going to
be resolved soon people are left unable
to send their kids to school unable to
put food on the table I'm unable to
secure a future for their children and
that's why I say they need hope they
need to know there are other options
other than taking to the Sea and trying
to reach Europe or any other country
hoping for a better future
um today and in the past three days we
heard about more than 90 almost 90
people who drowned in this journey many
more are still lost at sea the survivors
are you know there's about for now what
we hear from the Syrian authorities
about 20 survivors that's a tragic
number these are tragic figures and we
are we from what we get uh many of those
who were on the boat were women and
children and so you can only think what
was on the mind of these families when
they decided to go on this boat
definitely they did not see any other
option and that's why the International
Community has to come forward has to
provide support for international
humanitarian agencies to provide for
those who need support they have to
support countries like Lebanon in order
to be able to attend and and revive the
economy give Lebanese some hope that
things will improve and the
International Community has to provide
legal safe Pathways to for people who
wish to live another point that is very
important that the number of these of
these Journeys and departures from
Lebanon have increased and it's not just
from London we've seen it from Libya
from Tunis there has to be more effort
put to increase the capacity and more
important the will of the countries that
have the capacity to do so for rescue at
Sea operations there has to be some kind
of more guarantees for those who are
rescued to be disembarked at safe ports
to be received to be welcome and that
has not happened yet and it needs to it
needs to happen it's an important point
to make we appreciate your thoughts
ruler I mean senior Communications
advisor at the UN High Commissioner for
refugees thank you